l'accent sur les jambes sous les jupes
ultra courtes un bandeau de dentelles
festonnées qui cache qui marque la
cuisse découverte c'est le détail hiver
93 94 de la collection Yves Saint
Laurent
j'ai fait des femmes avec des jupes très
courtes et bordés de dentelle ce qui
fait qu'on croit que c'est la jarretelle
c'est des femmes
Hardy c'est des femmes champagnes oui
exactement
champagne comme le dernier né des
parfums qui ne se laisse pas éteindre
par la crise puis le costume d'homme
porté au féminin le cardigan souple en
crêpes noires glissant sur blues et
pantalon pyjama l'alliance sans complexe
et toujours
et de couleur que l'on aurait cru à la
consigne
et puis du noir des noirs profonds
ajouré sur la peau et noir éclairer le
rose pour animer le visage de brûlures
d'animaux chapeaux lumière d'un col
encadrant le visage
dans la démarche
Allah vous pouvez enfin vos yeux on va
joyeuse
et pour finir une très jeune mariée